The joe rogan experience. I think he
does whatever the fuck he wants. Yeah,
that's what I think.
That's the only thing that explains his
tweeting and all that crazy shit that he
says all the time. Perhaps. Yeah. I
mean that's just complete guessing.
No, I know him. I knew him.
Did you? Yeah. Fuck care.
Does it felt weird that he's a
president. Very. He called. Okay.
Amy over there worked for his wife
for seven years and then I got her
and I was in Maui sitting on my
bed and I get a phone call it song.
She was Jesus Christ. This
Donald, she hands me the phone.
Do you say the Donald or just don't know.
She said it's Donald [inaudible] were
three vodka. I'm just kidding. Melania.
She worked for Melania in the
family for seven years. Okay. Um,
I got the phone call, I pick it
up, I'm sitting down and I said,
we'll say hey Donald,
because we had been down to Mar
Lago and offered money to do shows,
one offs forum and just stuff. I've been
up, been up to his little castle and um,
he calls me up and I said,
Donald,
you can't use dream on as
for causes not campaigns.
And he did anyway.
He did anyway.
And I had to assume I got Dino's whom
sent him a letter of cease and desist.
So I've been through that shit.
So I kinda know where lawyers live.
You don't have his whole world's run by
lawyers and Donald's got 90 lawyers that
are telling them what the fuck. Okay.
Maybe he's not listening. Right.
But when everyone is saying,
if you just say John Mccain
is a fucking hero, if, if,
if we don't see John Mccain is a hero,
then how do you expect any young people
to one average joined the armed forces?
Because for everything they
do in bullets they take,
they're going to be laughed at
by presidents like Trump. Right.
What the fuck are you saying Donald?
Well he said something crazy like,
but you see what I'm saying? Soldiers
that don't get caught on things he said,
but, but they do, war is war.
Who wants the soldiers don't get
caught cause they want to. Exactly.
So I just tell you that you know he,
he's not saying anything because
he's being told what to do and see.
I think he just does whatever the fuck
he wants and if the lawyers tell him,
Steven says you can't play dream on,
and he's like fuck him.
I know it's what he did.
He played in any way so I had
sent them a cease and desist.
Then he sends a letter and said what when
I'm playing kid rock or fuck something
what? What did he found
a better song? He goes,
I found a better song. I actually
have, I'm going to frame it.
But that's his thing. You know he likes
people and you know what? That's a scene.
I see how that, how people get off
on his, what it isn't is I get this,
isn't he a precedent for this time though?
I mean this is the time we were talking
before the show about people trying to
drag people down and social media and
there's so much hostility and people are
looking to be angry and insult. This
is the time for that and a lot of ways,
unfortunately I wonder if
he's opening good peer,
he's opening Pandora's box for good
or is he opening Pandora's box choice?
I think it's our choice, but he's
our president. He's the president.
But I think we can respond to this bad
feeling that we have about those kinds of
actions in a positive way.
I think that's where there's an opening.
I think the opening is for people to
recognize that it's not going to live
forever. You can't insult people into the
grave and feel good when you're dying.
It doesn't matter.
Like what makes you feel good right now.
If something makes you feel good to
constantly be knocking people down and
shitting on their grave,
you probably a terrible person.
Nobody wants to be a terrible person.
At least the majority of people don't.
So I think the majority of people are
going to recognize that this path is a bad
one. Then it might feel good in
the short term to say, fuck you,
we're going to make America great again.
We're gonna fucking
light the world on fire.
But I think after a while when the
tide goes in and the tide goes out,
people are gonna realize that this
is not the way to go. Yeah. I hope,
I hope we're going to learn. I think
the world is getting better overall.
I think there's terrible moments that
have always existed throughout human
history, but I think overall, if you look
at the period of time we live in now,
you know,
and Steven pinker wrote a great big
book about this and there's a lot of
evidence in his book.
Lot evidence points to that.
Every now and then I'll find somebody
on, I'll read something, see something,
and I call my managers, get me his
number called Steven up. I'm from Boston.
I met him and had lunch. He's great
at the what called Crab, you know,
you know Boston? Yes. One of the best
restaurants on planet. The barking crap.
Crab fucking men. And I had lunch
with him and my Mary Jo Becker.
What a fucking slamming guy.
Yeah, he's a really kind person.
Is fucking smart as can be friendly.
Yeah. This is the kind of people,
this is the key. This is the, I agree with
you when it's time for lifting up. Yeah.
Well, I think that's going to happen.
It's a really fun thing is right now.
Okay.